Infinity's the only view this is a
sit-down I have a gold link who is an
incredibly interesting artist out of DC
and I thought we got into some really
interesting [ __ ] here four artists in a
certain place if you are kind of winning
right now you better watch this the rice
[Music]
how long you guys been together about
the management that we get love it how
long have you been paying attention
that's the same old [ __ ]
people that know no people that don't
know it's the same old [ __ ] it's like
watching the Music Awards last night I'm
like literally five years ago [ __ ] like
dudes are singing songs they wrote four
years ago like you know when you got to
hit that much middle America the same
old [ __ ] SoundCloud Spotify right it's
just the same so what so what's coming
next
like how are you guys think about that
what's the next move like what's the
next project or how are you strategizing
I was like we mean we build so much
culture - alright yes the thing about it
is
now that we got the Platinum and that
kind of came around one time yes it's
like we kind of want to transition this
song cruel whatever the one I would fly
to London tonight and kind of transition
that into a new single but also on the
back end we kind of want to do both
personally I'm gonna start investing go
to the child and start working on that
but more so it's just kind of like
trying to like expand the culture
outside of music because we did we kept
doing things okay we're great at that
you know saying so we kind of want to
show people that were more multifaceted
and kind of do things that basic are you
concerned about going too fast before
you really put the flag into the music
yeah it's the same should I'm always
doing yeah I want to go on to I mean
this is a great company and I build a
big ass company I can't wait to do what
I'm doing next which is buying brands
and do it but I'm always like you know
like did I really put it like you know
you know how many hit songs how many hit
projects before you could have the cuz
it's as soon as you move you're trading
off the equity you made in music and
you've got this much equity versus the
whole womb being fold it's a really
interesting thing to your point gradual
you know what the problem is this is the
toughest moment for this entire crew
peak because you've been hitting it hard
for so long now you're on that next
plane you've been thinking about the
next plane from the beginning let alone
for the five years and now the question
is do you move too quick it's
interesting you're independent right no
your side so anything I can help with
you you know obviously you guys having
some sense like anything specifically
please I think right now like it's funny
that you say that because especially all
the time the process of that transition
you're talking about so like even for
example like we're trying to get into
modeling but more so image consultants
so it's like we've met with like what is
it the society models
or they represent kim giman to those
people and then we met with funk was
asleep and alle so it's like we're doing
these things but even having the
conversations with those people and
talking about how brains don't know what
the [ __ ] they're doing as far as like
leave town there's no - [ __ ] they're
doing the orders no we don't know what
the [ __ ] were doing so so it's like for
that we're gonna try to make basically I
talked to him on the train when I was
coming up here he's kind of like you
want to do like a plane where it's like
we actually want to sit down and like
what is our a-to-z what do we want it to
look like what is it that we would even
want and what we figured that out we
kind of thought that space is over 20
times so until we figure that out so let
me give you a piece of ice what you want
is to gather as much attention as
possible
you guys are also locate the five guys
are all so young right you have like
4050 more professional years like don't
and be smart like we're all gonna be
living longer so like you know you see
you know I'm gonna be sitting courtside
of the Knicks game tonight
some 67 year old white dude with Easy's
on and the 30 year old girlfriend is
gonna sit right next to me
like life is long like people get
confused so so to be really frank with
you hey I love your answer and obviously
we don't a lot of time you got to go do
Fallon's so we need to chop it up again
together I thought it was going to DC
for some stupid reason soon but
nonetheless it's easy I love you sell it
sell is my favorite Baltimore Sun why
cuz you're pretty anyway
here's what I would say taking a step
back just something for you guys to chop
up with each other like what the [ __ ]
did he say like just a good like like
food for thought my point of view if
you've got this moment in music and I'm
gonna start doing more of my own
homework I've listened not as it's great
but like uh what whether by the way
whether it's modeling or music or [ __ ] I
don't give a [ __ ] gap that's why I love
social so much gather as much attention
as you can as much as you can because
you're gonna trade on that to your point
no matter what comes out of your guys
collective mouth we're gonna start a
beverage business we're gonna start
we're gonna create our own we're gonna
create our own label we're gonna we're
gonna start a we want a beats by dre
moment it's gonna be that [ __ ] rat ass
fly thing like whatever the [ __ ] you
guys are gonna say
all of it is gonna trade on one currency
attention the [ __ ] am i doing I'm just
gathering so much attention and then I
get to deploy it Mike a Swiss collab
outsold future and the weekend it makes
no [ __ ] sense like this much sense
because I'm more attention that people
realize and my attentions deep those
guys have way more attention than I do
but it's scattered on other things and
there isn't that's it there's connection
I'd be unfair but like that's right
just [ __ ] gaffe like what I what I
want for you and anybody else in your
position this young this much talent
this kind of collective crew you know to
me it's like it's why I always thought
Shrake was playing it right in what
here's what's smart about what Drake did
and I have no idea if this is what they
thought I just don't know but the volume
of projects that he put out speaks to my
thesis which is when you're hot [ __ ]
like when you've got the best hand
[ __ ] keep playing it yeah like to me
the thing now is to be overly thoughtful
of the next like like song because god
forbid you can go two in a row you guys
have been around your big boys you get a
second one it's a whole different
conversation mm-hmm and then that level
of attention is disproportionate I think
the other thing that I'm obsessed with
is who you collaborate with when I would
spend a lot of time on the Istana trains
going home on is we just did Fallon
everybody knows what's coming we're
poppin first who's reaching out to us
because they're a little bit tired we're
hot but they may be a bigger wide name
and who would you [ __ ] with write a you
know I love your reaction oh man do you
know that reaction right now when you
leave I'm gonna like he's gonna win
that's a very good reaction because you
understood what I just said who the [ __ ]
has big audience who's a little right
who's the usher the John Legend the Y
clef or whomever
however like right who's got real reach
but doesn't have your [ __ ] culture of
pull swag right now needs you for that
and you need it's a [ __ ] trade
why is that 67 year old gonna have a 25
year old [ __ ] smoke show it's a trade
I would be like if I was part of this
team like in the same way that's rad
that you're bitching like I would be
like growth consultant' about okay who's
reached out to us if anybody who does
the label desperately want to get a
little pulse into and who's authentic to
us like everybody else suck like silly
[ __ ] that nobody would think I'd be like
you would be like I always loved Billy
Joel I listen to Billy Joel all the time
in a Billy John Mayer John Muir's being
real smart right now I know Jeff uh-huh
he didn't tweet about Nicki Minaj for
his health he knows exactly the [ __ ]
he's doing like he's not [ __ ] with
exactly Russ and [ __ ] Metro boomin he
knows exactly what he's doing cuz he's a
gangster
you need to find him who's the who's
your John Mayer who do you [ __ ] with
who's reached out and get that song out
ASAP the collab that disproportionally
cuz the [ __ ] streets are [ __ ] with
you come on Kansas Susie to [ __ ] with
you
that would be what I'd be [ __ ]
spending all my time on tonight we're
gonna be put on to that mainstream [ __ ]
who the [ __ ] gonna reach out cuz the
[ __ ] Louie let me tell me this is
what I do
Louis Vuitton and Under Armour and
Reebok and everybody else they're all in
deep [ __ ] [ __ ] my man that game is
over I'm glad your reaction they're all
dead guys guys they're all dead
here's what that means instead of
worrying about that right now
go [ __ ] into attention-grabbing pop up
24 months you'll get pieces of equity in
Nautica [ __ ] a deal just a little more
patience right now at the time that it's
the hardest because you've been [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] and now you're here but
you're here do you know what I mean and
what's crazy is right now this is why
everybody this is why most people don't
win this is the time that you go even
more [ __ ] eating not the reverse
and it's so countercultural cuz you guys
not talking about this day for [ __ ]
every day for the last two thousand days
in a row
and now you're here and you think you're
here and it's like no no no and that's
what I did I [ __ ] invested in Facebook
Twitter Boober everything I'm here I did
it and I decided to build a client
service agency go into clients and each
[ __ ] in the prime of my career so I'm
giving you advice I took and now I'm
really here and I'm still not really you
know what it's like the longer you can
hold your breath you win but that
honestly what I would do right now is
[ __ ] circle up and be like who will
be doing a song with who's gonna do the
hook like who are we doing a straight
collab with that disproportionately puts
you in a much bigger awareness pool and
the best part is there's some big-ass
artists that really needs you right now
because you got the thing that they want
relevance and they've got what you want
audience that's exactly when you [ __ ]
do you know a song with Mariah Carey or
whatever is authentic or whatever you
guys [ __ ] with that's on you somebody
from DC I don't know you guys do you
I'm not never gonna I'm always gonna
frame it I'm not gonna tell you who but
the biggest audience that you can [ __ ]
with get in the studio tomorrow that's
what I would do that's my two cents you
know because the [ __ ] you guys are
thinking about is gonna be there for you
it's gonna be that you're gonna more
leverage cuz they're doing this and what
you need to do is make sure you go like
that not that because if you're thinking
about all their [ __ ] you'll stay flat
what you need to just get more attention
more attention more people listen that's
music that's your [ __ ] gay card right
now make sense and you see it you guys
look like the freshmen list or Spotify
rap caviar we all see it there's [ __ ]
people that have that moment and then
they they make a decision it's either to
sweat and penis everybody's like oh they
sort of partying mm-hmm I hate when
people do that people are smart now you
kids are way smarter than the kids that
came up when I was a kid like it's not
that they're partying and [ __ ] hoes
and like [ __ ] bi and dumb [ __ ] it's
that they [ __ ] are so excited about
that moment they start focusing on
what's my sneaker club and how am I
gonna do this cologne and I get it but
they didn't [ __ ]
didn't get it all yet and the one move
nobody does is the collaborations that's
why I'm giving it to you I want to give
them new fresh stuff that's the move cuz
its audience and people don't pay
attention like you know like people who
understand what [ __ ] Taylor Swift did
for Kendrick Lamar that's real [ __ ] man
oh oh
cuz he's smart cuz Kendrick told you
that his plan was to go on peoples [ __ ]
and steal their fans [ __ ] told you
he's right that's what I do when I go in
people's podcast like I'm coming of
course I'm coming on your show I'm
taking your [ __ ] people with me you
know like so and you're still young
enough in my opinion that you can win
both within your genre and outside of it
you still have a lot of hip-hop
collecting to do you do I believe in
that [ __ ] man I don't know man like two
songs look you [ __ ] Lipton I don't
tell you you live that you know what
better and I do did a bunch of project
now you're living through what happens
when you hit a song that [ __ ] compounds
when you get two in a row you know like
real different gigs
that's and it's like really 10x and
that's why if you get a collab that pops
you know we're spending a lot of time at
the Latin kids that are like Kings speak
English but you're gonna you know you
get on song with Bieber Khaled does this
like just cross everything's crossing I
would really spend a lot of time looking
at the artists that are ahead of you and
reach that you would [ __ ] with both in
your own genre and outside of your genre
and I would be very thoughtful of
anybody who reaches out and be like yo
[ __ ] with you like I mean like [ __ ]
hardcore like officially through the
label all the way to somebody like
giving you love on social best
collaborations that I know over like
somebody gave you love and just like
just tweeted some [ __ ] like this is
[ __ ] fire and you just DM them and
you're in the studio the next week it's
a different world patience and you know
it there's nothing I said you don't know
you know but the collab one it now that
that's the one like if I can be like oh
I'm so glad that happened cuz you like
that would be the one that I would be
very thoughtful about it could really
change it and you know what's crazy
about that's historically correct for
hip-hop guys I'm old
that Run DMC [ __ ] Aerosmith the thing
that changed everything for Run DMC
everything cuz I was in a very cult-like
mixed culture environment in New Jersey
and I like black friends and Indian
friends and white fans like me and my
black friends knew who Run DMC was that
Irish Smith joint put everybody on you
have the best part right now though you
can go deep into Atlanta or more like
collapse on the Wesker like you you're
still gonna benefit from anybody who's
just a bigger artist within your genre
let alone
maroon 5 yeah you don't you still up
both to do [ __ ] crazy big that's just
exactly right that's exactly right
though but now with this song it's you
could get now you could get the khalid
that is khalid today versus the clean
you got like now it's like just
exponential you got you and cleave put
out a song right now and nothing like
that would be like a hundred percent and
radio play and like and like target
wants it for a commercially like your
you got your computer in it now now you
gotta have the real conversation this is
where you got a real real smart about
these next to cool alright i don't wanna
hold you guys up go
I'll give some love I'll get some
followers for you take yourself I'm good
time today take care
leave your two cents to the interview to
the meeting I just had what go link we'd
love to see it and have a great great
healthy New Year
[Music]